bonsoir à tous alors je suis maxime je
suis chef de cuisine chez mr khalil
jemmah devant et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi ce soir pour moi quand on vous
sert une assiette au restaurant c'est un
peu la vision du monde du cuisinier ma
vision du monde un mois
un des bons produits et ce soir je vais
vous expliquer par trois secrets je vous
donnais trois secrets trois secrets du
chef pourront poser une assiette qui a
une âme parce que mon but en tant que
cuisinier c'est qu'au restaurant je
puisse vous transmettre ma passion
transmettre ce que je ressens quand je
cuisine et tout ça ça se passe dans
l'assiette
mon premier secret c'est de travailler
des produits imparfaits c1 semble un peu
bizarre mais je vous expliquer ça vous
voyez ça c'est une botte de carottes une
belle botte de carottes avec les fanes
bien vertes les carottes bien droites
facile joli on pourrait très vite
choisir ce genre de produits dont nos
supermarchés
et cette botte de carottes symbolise
pour moi ce qui n'est pas un bon produit
parce qu'elle est parfaite et que pour
moi un produit une carotte parfaite
c'est une carotte qui a du goût et une
carotte qui a du goût
ben généralement elle ressemble à ça
voilà mon produits imparfaits et mon
produit un parfait j'ai découvert après
quelques mois en tant que chef chez mr
quelques mois de boulot intense puisque
prendre un poste comme celui là c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de travail
la recherche s'est constitué une brigade
s'est passé beaucoup de temps beaucoup
de temps au boulot et j'avais besoin de
prendre l'air et pour prendre l'air je
suis allé voir un couple de maraîchers à
marcq en baroeul pour
approfondir le produit approfondir le
sujet produits j'avais envie de
comprendre comment pousser une carotte
comment pousser une pomme de terre
j'avais ma petite idée mais j'avais
envie d'aller rencontrer des gens qui
pourraient par la suite m'aider à
m'approvisionner et m'aider à comprendre
tout ça donc un marcq en baroeul j'ai
rencontré un couple de maraîchers et
tout de suite nous expliquer comme quoi
il y avait un tournant un tournant dans
leur vie parce que même s'ils sont
jeunes ils ont compris que le maraîcher
l'agriculteur a une une vie plus courte
que les autres
non pas parce que son métier plus
pénible mais parce que sur un champ en
agriculture conventionnelle
l'agriculture conventionnelle
l'agriculture parfaite
eh bien il faut répandre beaucoup
d'insecticides beaucoup de pesticides
beaucoup d'engrais pour que cela se
poussent très très vite et que ça fasse
du rendement on peut à 20 par avais pas
envie de ça il avait envie d'autre chose
et ils m'ont démontré que le fait de
travailler de la qualité travailler
moins de rendement travailler avec pas
travailler avec les mêmes clients
c'est-à-dire faire moins de volume
travailler en direct
eh bien ça pouvait fonctionner ça
pouvait fonctionner et du coup faire moi
faire meilleure qualité et travailler en
direct avec son consommateur puisqu'il
avait ouvert un petit magasin la ferme
et bien cela a permis de gagner mieux
leur vie d'avoir un confort de vie
meilleure et l'année dernière ils sont
partis en vacances
la preuve de leur succès ensuite pour
aller encore plus loin je vous présente
brice lui driss il est dans les flandres
côté belgique côté belgique et il
travaille en biodynamie la biodynamie
c'est cultiver un grand jardin où tout
se mélange un peu comme aller à la
maison il y a des mauvaises herbes et il
y a le fruit de la récolte
alors voilà par exemple il est au milieu
de son champ on distingue pas bien mais
il y a des carottes des navets delà des
betteraves de la moutarde des pousses de
partout il ya même des mauvaises herbes
et ses mauvaises herbes la noue
cuisiniers on les utilise et on les
mange maintenant donc il m'a fait
comprendre driss que la culture
conventionnelle pouvait être facilement
contré par une culture moins
conventionnel vous
coûteuse plus qualitatif plus soucieuse
de l'environnement et pour moi ça a été
un grand pas en avant de comprendre que
la culture conventionnelle qui nous
donnaient des choses un peu stéréotypé
et bien n'était pas révélatrice du goût
ni révélatrice de créativité puisque
quand on travaille un produit comme
celui-là faut être un peu plus créatifs
pour que ce soit joli dans l'assiette
donc voilà ces champs à driss là pour
vous expliquer vraiment qu'on cultive
tous en même temps
et puis j'ai poussé un peu plus loin
parce que les légumes c'est bien mais je
suis aussi rencontré des éleveurs et
notamment la famille de kits un père et
ses deux fils qui élève des pigeons
alors le pigeon chesaux il élève en
volière puisque ils ne sont pas dans la
gamme dans l'élevage conventionnels ils
ont décidé de ne pas les mettre en cage
pas élevés en batterie
et pourquoi ne pas élevé en batterie
pour limiter des maladies pour faire une
meilleure qualité
parce que l'élève de façon naturelle et
élever un pigeon de façon naturelle
c'est donner la chance à un couple de
pigeons d'avoir denis et d'élever l'un
et l'autre ni naturellement de concasser
le grain de donner à manger à l'heure à
leur petit ce qui va permettre à
l'oisillon de grandir naturellement de
développer des saveurs qui pour moi sont
un terreau est intéressante différentes
et d'une façon naturelle et ils ont vite
compris que le travail comme ça laissé
libre cours à la nature et bien y avait
pas besoin d'antibiotiques y avait pas
besoin de granulés et que chez eux c'est
naturel c'est naturel parce que juste le
fait de filtrer l'eau d'abord à une eau
de meilleure qualité un peu plus oxygéné
eh bien ça permettait d'avoir moins de
maladies et que l'antibiotique qui n'est
pas transmis à l'oisillon par ses
parents ça sert à rien de donner aux
parents parce que façon il va rien
donner
donc ça sert à rien de déformer la
nature voilà pourquoi le fait d'aller
rencontrer ces personnes
ça m'a permis de comprendre que là le
goût se trouve pas forcément dans un an
dans la beauté et que la qualité du
travail de ces personnes sera le reflet
de la qualité de mon travail sera
reflétée dans la qualité de mon travail
paie
ce pigeon il fait partie de mon deuxième
secret mon deuxième secret ses cuisines
et épicée alors pourquoi épicé parce que
pour moi les pis c'est vraiment le
synonyme du voyage dans une cuisine et
mon pigeon de stains bornes qui hélas
pas très loin de l'île jeu qui n'a
jamais volé puisqu'il à 30 jours et bien
j'en fais un pigeon voyageur au travail
et je fais une assiette épices et coloré
qui a du goût et qui a le goût de mes
voyages puisque j'ai commencé à voyager
après les études et je suis parti en
angleterre en angleterre pourquoi parce
que j'avais le souvenir
on disait tout le temps en angleterre on
y mange mal le film de de finesse où on
avait le plat typique de l'angleterre
avec ce flanc vert ça c'est la
gastronomie anglaise bien moi j'avais
envie de comprendre et savoir pourquoi
en angleterre on mangeait mal j'ai vite
pris une claque parce qu en angleterre
on mange très bien on mange très bien
parce que là bas quand on n'a pas la
chance d'avoir la grand-mère qui nous a
invités le dimanche midi à avoir un bon
petit plat qui nous a transmis son petit
secret qu'il a transmis à nos mamans qui
nous ont cuisiné des bons plats à la
maison quand on n'a pas cette culture
chose qui existe en angleterre
eh bien on cela crée et on s'inspire au
convoyage on part en france on par an
aux états unis on a en asie on se
nourrit de la culture qui nous entoure
pour arriver chez nous est révélé cette
culture et se crée une propre identité
cette création propre identité gelé
approfondie en australie parce que là
bas c'est encore pire quand on sait que
les premiers colons australiens étaient
des forçats et des prisonniers anglais
imaginez vous la qualité de la
gastronomie anglaise déportés en
australie ça pouvait rien faire de bon
et bien si 6 pourquoi parce qu'il ya une
vraie influence de ce qui les entoure
l'asie notamment et là bas j'ai
découvert la culture asiatique et
surtout l'accueil la cuisine
thaïlandaise richement riche en goût
riche en épices et riche en fraîcheur et
tout ça pour dire que là-bas j'ai
travaillé pendant sept mois en australie
et j'ai découvert que qu'il était
possible à notre époque de se créer une
identité et de se créer une culture
gastronomique
après ce passage bref en australie je
suis parti en en
en asie du sud-est et là-bas pendant
trois mois j'ai voyagé j'ai découvert
des choses et je me suis fait la vraie
une réflexion et un peu de révélations
c'est que quand on a pas ou quand les
coups quand les techniques modernes que
l'on a chez nous qui nous semble très
très accessible quand tout ça n'était
pas valable
il y encore quelques années en thaïlande
par exemple le frigo le congélateur
eh bien il fallait contrer le fait que
les produits pouvait rire rapidement et
il y a une vraie transmission en asie du
sud est la transmission culinaire est
très importante parce qu'avec un rien on
arrive à faire des mets délicieux et
pourquoi parce que la grand-mère a
expliqué comment faire un pas de taille
en mer a expliqué comment faire une
salade de mangue parce que ce sont les
fruits et les légumes et les autres
choses de l'environnement il manque ça
ça se cuisine sorties tombé de l'arbre
quand on a la charge et qu'elle est
rouverte bien il faut l'assaisonner et
tout ça ce sont des secrets et c'est
secret là ont été transmis de génération
en génération et ont permis de créer une
vraie identité que j'essaye parfois de
ramener mois en france et la
transmission
c'est un peu mon troisième secret mon
troisième secret qui est de poser le
plat sur la table alors mois au
restaurant c'est clair je vais pas vous
poser les plats sur la table ce serait
un peu incompréhensible et un peu
vulgaire mais à la maison posons les
plats sur la table est ce que je vais
expliquer par là c'est que la
transmission
quand on est passionné quand on a creusé
un peu son sujet quand on est allé un
petit peu plus loin que les autres
eh bien il faut le transmettre
transmettre à ma brigade ça c'est mon
métier
ok puisse faire à leur tour ce soir par
exemple puisque je n'y suis pas et
transmettre à mes clients transmettre à
mes clients ma passion le l'intérêt de
choisir l'intérêt de sélectionner
travailler avec des partenaires valable
des partenaires qui ont compris qu'on
pouvait faire changer les choses
en passant de de rendement à qualité en
passant de difficultés à plaisir c'est
aussi ma façon de transmettre le fait
qu' il faut s'ouvrir s'ouvrir à un monde
qui est riche réagir riche de bonnes
choses pour moi riche d'épicerie riche
de rencontres
et ça me permet de à mon tour rencontrer
des gens ont montré des gens au
restaurant on compterait des gens hors
du restaurant et notamment ça me permet
d'aller encore plus loin dans la
démarche est plus loin dans
l'explication
là je travaille on en a actuellement sur
un projet de social business avec une
grande sophie grandes sociétés sur la
création de soupe la création de soupe
qui va être produite par des chômeurs
longue durée avec des écarts de triage
l'écart de triage c'est ça ça c'est bien
le l'écart de triage comparé à ça
puisqu'on veut que du calibre est dans
notre dans notre grande distribution eh
bien on va se servir des produits qui
sont très très bons mais qui sont moins
jolie pour en faire des soupes
excellente que l'on va essayer de vendre
pour faire vivre ce social business
c'est aussi une rencontre avec la
l'association coeur et artères par
exemple pour essayer d'élaborer des
bento le bento qui serait une solution
repas pour ceux qui ont envie de manger
au travail ou solaires sur leur lieu de
travail un produit qu'ils ont cuisiné à
la maison sauf que c'est toujours
difficile de mettre un tupperware dans
son sac à main
ce risque qui s'ouvre et qui contamine
tout tout tout le sac
donc le projet c'est de d'essayer de
trouver des solutions à nos problèmes
pour mieux se nourrir au travail en le
faisant soi même en sélectionnant ses
produits et en sachant ce qu'on va
manger se faire plaisir bien manger et
le faire soi même et tout ça c'est en
relation avec l'association coeur et
artères et normalement ce projet là on
devrait le proposer à milan à milan sur
l'exposition universelle parce que le
fait d'annoncer aussi de creuser les
choses ça nous ouvre des portes
hélas ces données on part sur
l'exposition universelle avec
sur le pavillon lillois pour proposer
une un concept de restauration un petit
peu un petit peu différent puisque le
thème de la de l'exposition universelle
cette année c'est nourrir la planète
demain et donc on va proposer nos sous
pour proposer le bentô on va proposer le
fruit d'une agriculture raisonnée le
fruit d'un élevage raisonnée et tout ce
qui pour moi se révèle être une vraie
passion et un vrai pas en avant pour la
pour mon travail et pour ma pour ma
cuisine voilà merci